[Music]
let's go to amanda in new jersey what's
up amanda
hi john how are you i'm so good
you're the most joyful voice i've heard
in a long time mostly because i listened
to kelly and it was good to talk to you
you're a joyful voice too kelly it's
just at a lower octave and a little bit
meaner but it's still joyful still
joyful
okay hey amanda what are you doing how's
it going
oh it's going great thanks i'm having a
great wednesday so far excellent
excellent all right so what's up and how
can i help tell me what's going on
so my boyfriend and i have been dating
for about six months now um and a few
months ago i discovered that he was
liking
other girls pictures on social media
that were inappropriate
what is it what is it what does
inappropriate mean
um inappropriate like um
they were in maybe like skimpy underwear
um
showing off their goods
showing off the goods
all right awesome
um so i confronted him about it and he
reassured me that he loved me and that
he would stop doing it um so fast
forward a few weeks after that and i
discovered that he was back at it with
liking these girls pictures
my question is
am i being a jealous girlfriend or are
there red flags that i'm probably
overlooking
okay so let me
what do you think
or what do you feel
so
i love him he's the first man i've loved
um and i can see myself with him but
this is
to me it just makes me uncomfortable and
a little bit hurt that he's still doing
it yeah um
what what about
um
what about your
feelings towards this situation
what about your feelings have forced you
something about you have a feeling about
this you have a response to this and you
immediately roll it into well maybe me
it's probably me
i am probably feeling this way or maybe
i'm overreacting
what makes you think
so little of the way you feel about
something
um
so
maybe because it probably goes back to
when i was a kid but
i've grown up like my feelings have
always been kind of like invalidated
[Music]
i've
been known like oh jasmine you're just
overthinking you're you're making this a
bigger deal than what it is so into
adulthood i think i've carried that with
me and i'm just like oh maybe i'm just
making a big deal about this maybe i
should just
just let him have his fun and just
just sit back check out other people's
their goods
yeah right
okay
so the fact that you've now tethered
that connection
now because that's
finding that
pulling that string right from
now people have always told me that i
overreact that i'm being a baby or i'm a
whiner or whatever they've always told
me that to now that usually takes months
or some weeks sometimes months to
uncover that that road map right you've
got it yeah
now your task is to no longer go mining
in the past
but to begin to practice
trusting yourself moving forward
okay okay so here's what i would tell
you it's very very hard it's very hard
because you've been told that your steps
don't count you need to get in line
behind somebody else
and so
the feeling of jealousy especially when
you're dating is um
it's a it's a signal it's your body
telling you something and i always think
it's super wise to stop and ask like why
am i reacting this way
and
here's
the way i read it and the internets are
gonna say mean things about me that's
fine here's what they're gonna uh so
before the internet starts whining he
can do whatever he wants to he can
follow whoever he wants to in imaginary
land on social media that's not real but
he likes to think it is um he can
like any picture he wants to and the
women making these photos can do
whatever they want to
that's i've heard that many times they
can do whatever they want right that's
fine
he has no right
none zero
to stomp on your values
or on your wishes
or on the things that make you feel
uncomfortable in the relationship and
what you did was the right thing
you went to him with your values and
your discomfort and you said this
particular action
makes me feel less than
it makes me feel
um not enough
and i don't care if it was the way he
mowed your yard
i don't care if it was his views on
political issues i don't care what the
thing is
you were courageous and you went to him
and said
when you follow these other women
wearing hardly anything
and they are putting sexually explicit
material out there and you're into that
it makes me feel less than so i'm asking
you as your significant other to stop
and he said i'm in
you got it and then he lied to you and
went back
yeah
then
you are well within your rights to say
i'm uncomfortable with this relationship
and this is this to me the first time
it's about the discomfort thing
now it's about the lack of integrity and
his his disregard for your values
if he feels like
this is an affront to my values i think
i should be able to look at people on
the internet who freaking cares it's
fine
then a person with integrity would have
come back to his
girlfriend or his wife
and said
hey
i stopped doing this for a few weeks a
few months
and i'm troubled by this and here's why
i feel like you're acting like my mom i
feel like you are being unreasonable i
feel like this is just like play fantasy
but you are my real person like have
some sort of excuse some sort of
discussion
but don't just blow you off
okay okay yeah you deserve to not be
blown off
and you deserve to have have your values
recognized
and so if i'm you here's how this is i'm
just throwing something out there okay
okay i would circle back and say um this
happened again
do you want to be with me because i was
pretty clear about this makes me
uncomfortable
and
you're going
anytime we lay a boundary down
people run up and smash into it to see
if it holds
and he might say no i'm i mean if this
is that big of a deal to you we're
probably not gonna work out and if that
happens you have to hear me say this it
was never gonna work out
it might just fall apart five years from
now with two kids
yeah that's what i'm scared about
exactly yes and it's again it's not
about
hitting the little heart thing on
some woman in her underwear on social
media
it's about you being so courageous to
state your values and him being like i
don't really care
i'm gonna do whatever i want to and i
love you oh i love you but i'm gonna do
whatever i want to and you start when
you get those two competing messages you
feel crazy right because you're in the
gap yeah you feel nuts like he says he
loves me and i love him
but he but he's doing these other things
so if i'm you i would ask that question
if the answer is yes of course
then i would say then for 60 days for
two months i want you to delete all
social media
i want to i want i want you to show me
that i'm more important than a fantasy
world a not real world
and i put the stakes pretty high that's
just what i would do you don't have to
do that okay
okay
okay
that's that'll be hard but i will
definitely definitely try it how old are
you amanda
i'm 27.
are you settling
i
think deep down inside i may be okay
that's hard for me to admit no i know i
know i know and this isn't and by the
way this isn't because
he looks at people in their
like sexy pictures online that's not
that's not it just because somebody does
that doesn't mean somebody's settling
right
yeah
but my guess is there's deeper value
things here that you are slowly
wallpapering over
for the sake of this relationship slash
for the sake of this guy
oh boy okay
am i right
yeah you're you're right
i think i was just pushing it back and
i'm
kind of masking it was just like oh
you're just
like maybe just see how this plays out
but
yeah you're you're right
it's always it's it's almost never about
well i don't say that
i usually don't look at behavior first
because people say and do dumb things
that's just life and i am first in line
there i say and do dumb things
but i always want to roll back to
people's values
and
after i say hey here's a value for me
um does somebody else meet that value
when my wife says hey
i can't be a part of this
then i have to hear and meet her value
or i've got to leave
you know what i mean because values are
hard they're in stone
and
for whatever it's worth a man it don't
settle
okay okay
okay i'm trying not to cry but you're
you're right you're welcome to cry but
i'm not i
you've known this for a while right
yeah yeah i think i just pushed it to
the side yeah because it feels good to
have somebody with you right
yeah
it feels so good
and holding hands is good and making out
is good and laughter and joy is good
having someone to do things with is good
but man having somebody walk all over
the things that you think are important
to who you are and who you want to be
are not good
yes very true and i've seen it happen
with
my parents um my dad has
always he hasn't been faithful to my mom
throughout the year so
my biggest fear was always ending up in
the same situation
my mom i guess yeah so can i can i give
you one
nugget of wisdom that i want
you to put in your backpack okay yes
actually tattoo this one on your forearm
okay the way to break that cycle and it
does become a cycle
what we normally do to try to fix that
cycle is we try to be better for other
people
okay
so i'm imagining that you watched your
dad be unfaithful and there's all kinds
of stories about why that happened and
the reasons behind that et cetera
a logical path forward is i'm gonna be
the best girlfriend wife ever
i'm gonna be so good
that that can never
happen and it's when people realize that
most of the time
infidelity
is because the person who is
not faithful doesn't like who they are
it's not because of the other person
so the greatest gift you can provide in
your relationship moving forward any
relationship you're a part of
is that you don't seek to make sure
everybody else sees you as great
but that from the inside out you heal
and realize i'm who i freaking am
because i'm amanda from new jersey
right
yes it's you healing from the inside out
and there's something radiant about that
is there something so highly magnetic
about people who are whole from the
inside out
it's just like so true it's it's
incredible you're you've you've met them
before you've seen them and you talk to
them like oh what is that
it's just that they are at peace with
who they are they're at peace with who
they are
and it's it's just
so i'm not telling you to break up with
this guy you do what you're gonna do
i'm telling you that you are worth more
than having somebody spit on your values
you're worth more than trying to become
something so that somebody will be
faithful to you
but they will love you
that becomes performative and at some
point the lights go out in the theater
and the curtain closes and the
performance ends
and that's when you find out who you
really are
and that person amanda is worth being
loved